[موسيقى]
بتوقيت الرياضه وهذه اخبار الساعه
زعيم يعترف بشراسه الاوكران في القتال
ويرد على شايجو نحن من قاتلنا في باخموت
وليس جيشك
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه واكيد انفتاح
المملكه على الحوار مع ايران وان الاتفاق
النووي يجب ان يعالج مخاوف دول الجوار
20 محاميا ايرانيا يطالبون منظمات دوليه
بتشكيل لجنه مستقله للتحقيق في قضيه تصميم
الطالبات في ايران
تيك توك صيني ضمن مشروع قرار امريكي
يستهدف شركات التكنولوجيا الصينيه
[موسيقى]
وصلت موقفنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
التي تبدا من الحرب في اوكرانيا حيث صرح
قائد مجموعه فاغنري ان قوته هي من قتلت
الجنود الاوكراني حول باخمت وليس الجيش
الروسي كما صرح وزير الدفاع
كمان انتقدت تقليل من شان القوات
الاوكرانيه قائلا بانها تقاتل كمروس
شقاق في البيت الواحد اظهرته التصريحات
المتبادله بين السريش ويك وزير الدفاع
الروسي ويفجيني بريكوجين قائد مجموعه
فاغنر شويغو صرح بان القوات الروسيه قتلت
11 الف جنديا اوكراني حول بخمه خلال
فبراير رد قائد فجنر كان سريعا على وزير
الدفاع الروسي ان مجموعته من فعلت ذلك
اعتقد ان وزير الدفاع قيمهم بشكل صحيح لقد
قتلت شركه فاجنر حوالي 11 الف شخص في
فبراير
قائد فاغنورين انتقدت تقليل من شان القوات
الاوكرانيه وطلب قاده روسيا بعدم وصفهم
بالجبناء
الاوكرانيون لا يهربون انهم يموتون بشكل
جماعي من اجل باخموت ويستسلمون فقط كملاذ
اخير توقفوا عن وصفهم بالجبناء انهم مثلنا
ونفس الدم يتدفق فيهم
والمعارك حول مدينه بخموت مستمره روسيا
تحاول بشتى الطرق الاستيلاء عليها وقوات
كييف تحاول صدها تحليل نشر على موقع شبكه
سي ان ان سلط الضوء على الهجمات التي
تشنها القوات الروسيه للسيطره على باخمت
وقالت انه حتى لو تمكنت من الانتصار
فسيكون انتصارا باهظ الثمن اما هيئه
الاركان العامه للقوات المسلحه في
اوكرانيا فاعلنت ان الجيش الاوكراني قتل
اكثر من الف جندي امس فقط مضيفه ان القوات
الروسيه خاسره اكثر من ثلاثه الاف دبابه
وسته الاف مركبه مدرعه قتاليه والمئات من
الانظمه المدفعيه وانظمه اطلاق الصواريخ
المتعدده وانظمه الدفاع الجوي والطائرات
المقاتله والمروحيات والمركبات الاليه
[موسيقى]
وفي السياقه كذا الرئيس الاوكراني على ان
قرار ارسال تعزيزات للدفاع عن باخمت في
شرق البلاد كان بالاجماع نافيا التكهنات
المتعلقه بانسحاب قواته امام الجيش الروسي
الذي يحاول منذ تسعه اشهر محاصره هذه
المدينه
فاكتشفنا صامت طاقم العمل هذا الموقف
بالاجماع ولم تكن هناك مناصب اخرى لقد قلت
للقائد العام ان يجد القوات ذات الصله
لمساعده رجالنا في باخموت اظهرت لقطات
فيديو كيف قتل المحتلون بوحشيه الجندي
الذي قال لهم بشجاعه في عيونهم المجد
لاوكرانيا اريد ان نتحد جميعا لنرد على
كلماته المجد للابطال المجد لاوكرانيا
وسنجد القتله اينما كانوا
من جهه اكد وزير الدفاع الروسي ان السيطره
على باخ موت شرقي اوكرانيا اساسيه للتقدم
اكثر في اراضي الجاره الغربيه
تحرير بخمه مستمر هذه المدينه هي مركز
دفاعي مهم للقوات الاوكرانيه في دون باس
وستتيح السيطره عليها مزيدا من العمليات
الهجوميه في عمق دفاع القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه كجزء من الاستراتيجيه
الامريكيه المتمثله في كسر روسيا بقوه
السلاح تعمل الدول الغربيه على زياده
امداد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه والمعدات
العسكريه وتوسيع برامج التدريب لافراد
الجيش الاوكراني وفي الوقت نفسه هناك
زياده كبيره في الخسائر بين افراد القوات
المسلحه الامريكيه ففي فبراير فقط ازدادت
الخسائر باكثر من 40% مقارنه بيناير وبلغ
عددهم اكثر من 11 الف جندي
معركه باخوت التي اشعلت الشتاء الاوكراني
باتت تحمل الرمزيه الاكبر في الصراع
الروسي الاوكراني
المدينه التي تسمى ايضا
تقع شرقيه اوكرانيا شماليه اقليم دونيتس
تحديدا والذي تتقاسم القوات الروسيه
والاوكرانيه السيطره عليه القتال الدموي
المستمر منذ اشهر في المدينه والذي حمل
تقدم الروسيا في الايام الاخيره ادى الى
قطع الطرق المؤديه اليها باستثناء طريق
وحيده تصل الى الغرب سلطات دنيا المواليه
لروسيا تزعم ان القوات الروسيه استطاعت
السيطره على نصف المدينه محققه تقدما من
الجهتين الشماليه والجنوبيه
قتال مستميل تراه موسكو ذا اهميه
استراتيجيه كبيره للتوغل باتجاه الغرب
الذي تسيطر عليه خاصه وان الهدف التالي
سيكون المدينتين المفتاحتين كراماتورسك
وسلفيانك
تشكل المدينه مركزا دفاعيا مهما للقوات
الاوكرانيه في منطقه دومباس والسيطره
عليها ستسمح بهجمات اضافيه في عمق خطوط
الدفاع القوه المسلحه الاوكرانيه لكن رغم
كل هذه الاهميه من وجهه النظر الروسيه فان
واشنطن تقصر اهميه المدينه على الناحيه
الرمزيه وليس الاستراتيجيه وتؤكد ان
التقدم الروسي فيها لن يعني تغيير مسار
المعركه الى عمر العربيه
[موسيقى]
الى العاصمه الاوكرانيه معي من هناك
مراسلنا حذيفه عادل حذيفه اهلا بك حتى
رئيس مجموعه فاقنر اشاد ببساله القوات
الاوكرانيه في بخمه هل مازال الجنود
الاوكران صامدين في باخمت
مساء الخير صهيب هذا هدف استراتيجي الان
للجيش الاوكراني وهو الصمود في هذه الجبهه
واستنزاف القوات الروسيه
وتدمير اكبر عدد وتحييت اكبر عدد من
الجنود الروس وتدمير اكبر عدد من الاليات
العسكريه ذلك نسبه لان الروس اصبحوا
يركزون بشكل اساسي على هذه الجبهه هذا ما
جاء على لسان الرئيس فلاديمير الذي قال ان
خطه الدفاع عن باقي مت وعمليه الدفاع عن
باخ عم باخ تؤدي غرضها بشكل اتام طيب هل
بدات تنفيذ هذه الخطه لزياده الدفاع حذيفه
هل هناك معلومات عن التعزيزات التي يتم
ارسالها الى الى الجبهه هناك عن سير
المعارك وتطوراتها في هذا اليوم
[تصفيق]
صحيح الجبهه الشماليه على الرغم من ان
القوات الروسيه تقدمت بعض الشيء الا ان
القوات
الاوكرانيه استطاعت ان توقف هذا التقدم
وتعزز الدفاعات هناك وتقوم
يعني بناء دفاعات استراتيجيه كذلك الجبهه
المقابله لها من جهه ومارينكا ايضا
استطاعت ان تصد الهجمات من قبل الاتحاد
الروسي وان توقف تقدمهم بشكل عام هنالك
تعزيزات وصلت بالفعل الى المدينه على
الرغم من ان القوات الروسيه جعلت عمليه
ايصال الامدادات صعبه جدا ذلك نسبه لان
الروس قصفوا الجسر من اتجاه شاص نافيار
الذي كان يمثل معبرا لهذه الامدادات ولكن
هنالك طرق ترابيه بديله تستخدمها القوات
الاوكرانيه قام قائد القوات البريه بدفع
المزيد من التعزيزات وتهيئه الظروف للتمسك
بهذه الجبهه بشكل كبير هذا لا ينفي ان اذا
ما تطلب الامر سوف يكون هنالك انسحاب
استراتيجي قد جهزت القوات الاوكرانيه
دفاعاتها غرب المدينه بهذا الاحتمال سهيل
حذيفه باخمت كان عدد سكانها يناهز او
حوالي 71 الف نسمه بقي منهم اربعه الاف
فقط مع استمرار المعارك هناك لاكثر من سته
اشهر الان هل سيتم اجلاء المدنيين او يتم
حاليا اجلاء المدنيين مع الاستمرار في هذه
المعارك ام لا
في الحقيقه عمليه اجلاء المدنيين معقده
وصعبه جدا في الوقت الحالي المواطنين
الذين بقوا كان قد ناشدتهم السلطان
وناسدهم العسكريون بشكل كبير في الفتره
الماضيه بالخروج من المدينه ولكنهم رفضوا
وفضلوا البقاء هنالك كما تفضلت قبل قليل
اربعه الاف بينهم 38 طفلا في المدينه في
الوقت الحالي اخر عمليه اجلاء تمت
للمواطنين في اثناء خروجهم تم استهداف
سياره لمواطنين مدنيين قتلت امراه واصيبه
رجلان في هذه السياره لذلك الان عمليه
الاجلاء التتم على الاقدام سيرا على
الاقدام حتى لا يتم استهداف السيارات بشكل
عام هنالك جهود الان لهذا الاجلاء كما انه
تم اليوم استصدار قانون من قبل مجلس
الوزراء الاوكراني
الاجلاء او الاخلاء القسري للاطفال الامر
الذي لم يكن قانونيا في السابق يعني عندما
يتقدمون عندما ياتي الجنود لعمليه الاجلاء
والاقلاع عندما يرفض الوالدين لا يستطيعون
ان يفعلوا شيء لان القانون لا يحضر ذلك
ولكن الان بقوه القانون يجب اجلال الاطفال
قصرا حذيفه عادل مباشره من كييف
[موسيقى]
وفيما تحتدم المعارك في اوكرانيا افادت
صحيفه
بان روسيا تتردد في شراء صواريخ باليستيه
من ايران خشيه توجه حلفاء اوكرانيا نحو
تزويداب بصواريخ بعيده المدى ردا على هذه
الخطوه حسبما نقلته عن مسؤولين غربيين
اما بالنسبه لتصليح اوكرانيا فتداعيات
بتتخرج الى العلن في اوروبا حيث حذر
برلمانيون بريطانيون من ان اعاده بناء
مخزون بريطانيا المتضائل من الذخائر بعد
الحرب في اوكرانيا قد يستغرق عقدا على
الاقل مما يعرض الامن القومي البريطاني
للخطر فيما قالت لجنه الدفاع في مجلس
العموم البريطاني ان لندن وحلفاء اخرين في
حلف شمال الاطلسي سمحوا بانخفاض
احتياطياتهم من الذخيره الى مستويات خطيره
في الوقت الذي يسعون فيه الى ابقاء كييف
مزوده بالذخيره في كفاحها ضد روسيا
[موسيقى]
حرب
اودو
الجيش الاوكراني للخطر ويعرضها لخطر عدم
القدره على مواجهه التهديدات التي تطال
امنها في المستقبل
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه من بغداد واشنطن
وبرلين تحذران من خطر ايران على المنطقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نقل مرسل العربيه تعليقه
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه فيصل بن فرحان على
الاحداث الاخيره في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
حيث اكد ان هناك احتماليه حدوث عنف اكبر
اذا لم يتم حل القضيه الفلسطينيه واشدد
ابن فرحان ان موقف بلاده واضح من القضيه
الفلسطينيه وهو استقرار وامن الفلسطينيين
اما بالنسبه للوضع في سوريا فنقل مراسل
العربيه عن وزير الخارجيه السعودي قوله
انه يوجد اجماع على ان الوضع في سوريا ليس
مقبولا مضيفا انه يوجد حوار لعوده سوريا
الى الحضن العربي لكن من المبكر الحديث عن
ذلك من فرحان اضاف ايضا ان العلاقه مع
البيت الابيض جيده جدا وان الصين من اكبر
الحلفاء التجاريين للرياض كما هي مع باقي
العالم وحول اسواق الطاقه اكد وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه ان وزاره الطاقه لا ترى
حاجه لتغيير انتاج النفط هذا العام وان
السعوديه
ملزمه باستقرار اسواق الطاقه وفيما يتعلق
بملف ايران النووي اوضح وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه ان الاتفاق النوويه مع ايران ليس
مثاليا ويجب ان يعالج مخاوف دول الجوار
مؤكدا ان السعوديه منفتحه على الحوار مع
ايران
اناقش هذه هي التصريحات من الرياض مع
الدكتور محمد السلمي رئيس المعهد الدولي
للدراسات الايرانيه دكتور اهلا بك معنا في
اخبار الساعه وزير الخارجيه السعودي كما
تابعنا قبل قليل في هذه التصريحات الامير
فيصل بن فرحان قال ان الاتفاق النووي مع
ايران ليس مثاليا ويجب ان يعالج مخاوف دول
الجوار ما هو الاتفاق المثالي بالنسبه
للسعوديه والدول الخليجيه كذلك
اهلا وسهلا بك استاذ صهيب ولعلي في
البدايه نهنئ العربيه وطاقمها بدخولها
العقد الثالث الحقيقه اتمنى لها مزيد من
التوفيق لا شك ان المملكه واضحه جدا في
هذا الجانب وهي ترى ان اتفاق النووي
السابق
ركز على ملف مهم
ولكنه لم ياخذ بعين الاعتبار الملفات
الاخرى التي تهم المنطقه كان التركيز على
البرنامج النووي الايراني وهو ملف مهم لكن
هناك ملفين اخرين هما البرنامج الصاروخي
البالستي الايراني والنشاط او السلوك
الايراني في المنطقه
ولعل هذين الملفين يعني من المتابع يلحظ
بدقه انهما يؤثران بشكل كبير على امن
المنطقه في الوقت الراهن بينما الاتفاق
النووي او البرنامج النووي وان كان مهما
واكرر هذه النقطه الا انه
يعني مخاوف مستقبليه لدينا سلوك ايراني
واضح لدينا تزويد ايران للمليشيات
بالصواريخ الباليستيه وبي الطائرات
المسيره ولم ينحصر هذا السلوك الايراني
وتصدير قدراتها في الطائرات المسيره التي
معظم قطاعها وللاسف الشديد تاتي من الدول
الغربيه بنسبه تتجاوز السبعين في المئه
ولهذا يعني انحصر ليس منحصرا في المنطقه
لكنه ايضا وصل الى صراع لاوكرانيا الروسي
وبالتالي المملكه ترى ان اي اتفاق مستقبلي
يعني لضمان ديمومه اي اتفاق يجب ان يتضمن
الابعاد الاخرى هذه الملفات هذا الخطر هذا
الصواريخ الباليستيه وكذلك دعم الجماعات
في المنطقه العربيه الدول الجوار طيب ولكن
جولات عديده من محاولات احياء هذا الاتفاق
النووي لم تنجح في احيائه بعد دكتور محمد
وايران
ذهبت للاخلال بالتزاماتها في الاتفاق
السابق اتفاق 2015 هل برايك الان في ظل
المعطيات الحاليه ايران ممكن ان تقدم
المزيد يعني من
التنازلات من جانبها في اي اتفاق جديد
من يفهم السلوك الايراني والسياسه
الخارجيه الايرانيه انها لا تعمل لا يمكن
ان تقدم المزيد من التنازلات او حتى
تنازلاته او الوصول للاتفاق الا ان تكون
تحت ضغط كبير وبهذا هناك ضغط من الوكاله
الدوليه وهناك اجماع من المجتمع الدولي
بشكل عام حول ضروره معالجه الملف النووي
الايراني وضمان عدم وصول ايران الى سلاح
النووي ولهذا هناك جهود دبلوماسيه كبيره
تعمل على المستوى الاقليمي والدولي لايقاف
السلوك الايراني ولهذا نعتقد انه ما لم
يكن هناك ضغوطات
وتفعيل وليس فقط اعلان تفعيل للعقوبات فان
ايران لن ترضخ لقضيه المفاوضات نعم فيصل
بن فرحان قال نحن منفتحون على الحوار مع
ايران دكتور محمد هل تعتقد انه يمكن ان
نشهد حوارا سعوديا ايرانيا ومتى ووفق اي
معايير
لا شك ان السياسه السعوديه الخارجيه واضحه
في هذه الجانب وليس بجديد ان نتحدث عن
المملكه دائما الى الحوار والسلام وارسال
الامن والاستقرار في منطقه ملتهبه وان من
يفهم الرؤيه المملكه 2030 واقراها بشكل
جيد يدرك انها تركز على الامن واستقرار
والمشاركه ولهذا نحن يعني يعني شاهدنا
خلال سنتين الماضيه ربما من ابريل عام
2020 سنتين ونيف خمس جولات من المفاوضات
مع ايران ولا استبعد ان يكون هناك جوله
سادسه اذا كان هناك جديه من الجانب
الايراني الجولات الخامس الماضيه كانت في
وجهه نظريه ومن وجهه نظري هي حوار من نجم
الحوار من الجانب الاخر الايراني لسما
فيما يتعلق بالملفات الاخرى وضروره كان
هناك مطالب بضروره ادخال سلوك ايران في
المنطقه وحل الخلافات مع دول الجوار في
برنامج اتفاق النو ولهذا ايران نجاتي الى
هذا الجانب المملكه تدرك هذه الخطه
الايرانيه لكنها لا تقفل الباب يعني في
يعني تقفل الباب في وجه الحوار وتريد ان
تصل الى تفاهمات في هذا الجانب تبقى الكره
في وجهه نظري في المرمى الايراني اذا كان
هناك فعلا جديه لا سيما في ظل التحديات
الكبيره اللي هي شدت داخل الايراني ولا
سيما في التهديدات العسكريه الكبيره
الحقيقه التي قد تجد من خلالها صيفا ساخنا
خلال الفتره القادمه ان تدرك هذه المخاطر
على الشعب الايراني قبل غيره وتلجا الى
حوار جاد وبناء مع دول الجوار ليس تكتيكيا
بل استراتيجيا وهذا سيعود بالنفع على
المجتمع الايراني قبل غيره الى جانب لا شك
دول المنطقه بشكل عام الدول المنطقه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه في مقدمتها ترى
ان الحل هو في الحوار والمسار الدبلوماسي
الجولات الخمس الماضيه كانت في بعدها
الامني لكننا اذا راينا جديه من الجانب
الايراني فلا اعتقد لا استبعد ان يكون
هناك حوار دبلوماسيا في نهايه المطاف
الكره كما ذكرت في المرمى الايراني ونتمنى
نصل الى حل لخلافاتنا مع ايران نتمنى ذلك
الدكتور محمد السلمي شكرا جزيلا لك على
تلبيه دعوه اخبار الساعه من العربيه هذا
المساء مباشره من الرياض
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي ان رئيس الوزراء
العراقيه اكد له ضمانه ان القوات
الامريكيه في العراق من جهات غير تابعه
للدوله في اشاره الى الميليشيات المواليه
لايران
يجب ان نكون قادرين على العمل بسلامه
وامان لتنفيذ دور الحيوي لتقديم المشوره
للقوات العراقيه لذا اود ان اشكر رئيس
الوزراء السوداني ووزير الدفاع العباسي
على التزامهما اليوم بضمان ان قوات
التحالف الموجوده في العراق بطلب عراقي
ستتم حمايتها من العناصر التابعه وغير
التابعه للدوله نركز على مهمه هزيمه داعش
هذا هو هدفنا الوحيد هنا والتهديدات
والهجمات على قواتنا تقوض مهمتنا
التحذير الامريكي لطهران شاركه اخر الماني
انتقدت وزيره خارجيه المانيا
التدخل الايراني في العراق قائله ان
النظام يضع المنطقه باسرها تحت التهديد
على الدول ان تحترم سياده العراق كما
نتوقع منها ان تحترم سياده كل الدول
الاوروبيه ويظهر النظام الايراني بهجمته
الصاروخيه انه لا يضطهد شعبه بقسوه ووحشيه
فحسب بل يضع حياه الناس والاستقرار في
المنطقه كلها تحت الخطر في سبيل الحفاظ
على قوته وهذا امر غير مقبول وخطير على
المنطقه كامله
من بغداد بمعنى مراسلنا منتظر رشيد منتظر
اهلا بك الوزيران الامريكي
في زيارتهما الى بغداد عن الخطر الايراني
هلا اجملت لنا اهم التصريحات والمواقف من
المسؤولين الغربيين ونتائج الزيارتين كذلك
نعم بالنسبه لوزير الدفاع الامريكي تحدث
صراحه عن انه حصل على ضمانات من حكومه
السوداني بان لا تتعرض للقوافل اللوجستيه
الدعم اللوجستيه التي تاتي من الكويت
باتجاه ثلاثه قواعد رئيسيه الاولى في
محافظه الانبار وهي قاعده عين الاسد وصولا
طبعا الى قاعده فيكتوري في مطار بغداد
اضافه الى قاعده حرير في اقصى الشمال
العراقي في اربيل بالتالي يتواجد في هذه
القواعد طبعا مستشارون امريكيون مدربون
خبراء في عمليات الرصد وايضا تقديم
المعلومات للقوات الخاصه العراقيه في رصد
تحركات داعش واستهداف قياديها اضافه الى
تقديم دعم لوجستيين يتمثل طبعا بالطائرات
الامريكيه والمعلومات ورصد كل الاماكن
التي تتحرك فيها قاده التنظيم بالنسبه
لهذه الزياره زياره وزير الدفاع الامريكي
لم تكن معلنه طبعا فوجئ الكثيرون بوصوله
طبعا الى بغداد لاسباب امنيه طبعا لم يجري
الحديث عن هذه الزياره قبل حدوثها بالنسبه
لردود الافعال طبعا عليها نتحدث هنا عن
ابرز ردود الافعال كانت ساعود الى ردود
الافعال لو سمحت لمنتظر ولكن حدثني ايضا
على نتائج كذلك زياره الوزير الالمانيه
وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
نعم التصريحات الالمانيه طبعا فيما يتعلق
بايران ليست جديده لكن الجديد فيها انها
جاءت من بغداد حيث تحدثت صراحه عن انتهاك
السياده العراقيه من قبل ايران بعد قصفها
طبعا عددا من القرى داخل الاراضي العراقي
بصواريخ باليستيه هذا التطور الخطير هو ما
حدا طبعا بالوزيره الالمانيه ان تدلي بهذه
التصريحات طبعا شديده اللهجه تجاه ايران
من بغداد هذا هو الجديد في هذه التصريحات
لكن الزياره الالمانيه لوزاره الخارجيه
الشهيد التوقيع ثلاثه عقود كبيره جدا فيما
يتعلق بتوليد الطاقه الكهربائيه وثلاثه
محطات من قبل شركه ممتاز والعراق بحاجه
الى الكهرباء بشكل كبير طيب على ذكر ردود
الافعال المنتظر كما كنت تتحدث
الميليشيات المواليه لايران في العراق لم
تعجبها زياره وزير الدفاع الامريكي منها
حزب الله العراقي طبعا الذي قال انه
اي اتفاق بين حكومه السوداني
والامريكيين هم ليسوا ملزمين به ماذا
قالوا بعد
يعني ابو علي العسكري حساب طبعا
مقرب من كتاب حزب الله هجم صراحه هذه هي
الزياره وحتى انتقد كل المسؤولين
العراقيين الذين استقبلوه اضافه الى قاده
فصائل اخرى النجباء كتاب سيدي الشهداء
اضافه الى فصائل اخرى العصائب كلهم
انتقدوا هذه الزياره وصفوا وزير الخارجيه
بانه ضيف غير مرحب به اصلا اضافه الى انه
جاء من الشباك ولم ياتي من الباب في اشاره
طبعا الى عدم الاعلان عن هذه الزياره
بالتالي عاصفه من ردود الفعل الغاضبه كانت
من قبل هذه الفصائل والمتحدثين باسمها
وقادتها لكن على المستوى الرسمي جرى
استقباله طبعا في بغداد ومن ثم توجه وزير
الدفاع الامريكيه ايضا الى اربيل التي
التقى فيها رئيس الاقليم نجف فان بارزاني
قبل ان يغادر العراق
منتظر رشيد مباشره من بغداد
[موسيقى]
احتجاجات وتظاهرات شعارات مناهضه للنظام
الايراني ولا صوت يعلو على صوت الغضب في
الشوارع الايرانيه في اخر القضايا التي
شغلت الراي العام في ايران حالات التسمم
التي اجتاحت المدارس وجديد القضيه طالب
عشرون محاميا ايرانيا اربعه منظمات دوليه
بتشكيل لجنه مستقله ومشتركه لارسالها الى
ايران للتحقيق بشان القضايا الاربعه
التاليه ما اصل هذه التسممات المتسلسله
لماذا تورطت المدارس الايرانيه فيها لما
تم استهداف الطالبات بالتحديد وما
الاجراءات التي يجب اتخاذها من اجل
المساعده وقد تم ارسال هذه الرساله الى
المدير العام لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
والمدير العام لمنظمه الامم المتحده
للتربيه والعلوم والثقافه والمدير
التنفيذي لمنظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله
ورئيس اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر هذا
واتهم احد الطلاب في جامعه الاهواز علي
سعيد جليلي ممثل المرشد الايراني في
المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي الايراني
والنظام اتهمهم بالعجز عن حمايه الاطفال
في المدارس من السموم التي تستهدفهم
اذا قلتم ان التسميم في المدارس ليس من
فعلكم بل وراءه الاجانب عفوا اذا انتم
فاشلون جدا لانكم لا تستطيعون ضمان سلامه
هؤلاء الاطفال
وتعليقا على حالات التسمم التي اصابت
المدارس الايرانيه اعلن البيت الابيض ان
تحقيق في حالات تسميم جديده تعرضت لها
تلميذات في ايران يمكن ان يكون من ضمن
صلاحيات بعثه الامم المتحده لتقصي الحقائق
في البلاد واشددت المتحدثه باسم البيت
الابيض كارين جون كير على انه يجب ان يكون
هناك تحقيق مستقل ذو مصداقيه وان يعاقب
المسؤولون عنه
فرضت عقوبات اوروبيه ضد مسؤولين في سجن
قرجاك الايراني بسبب تعنيف المعتقلات وفق
ما اكده مراسل العربيه واوضح الاتحاد
الاوروبي ان بعض المعتقلات والناشطات في
هذا السجن حوامل يعشنا في ظروف قاسيه
ويعانين من اكتظاظ الزنزانات ونقص العلاج
واضاف ان سلطات سجن قرجك الايرانيه تستخدم
التعذيب والاغتصاب والعنف الجنسي كوسيله
لانتزاع الاعترافات من السجينات
[موسيقى]
بقوه خاصه اقتحم الجيش الاسرائيلي مدينه
جنين ومخيمها في الضفه الغربيه وسط
اشتباكات مع فلسطينيين الشبكات قتل خلالها
سته فلسطينيين على الاقل واصيب اخرون حسب
ما افادت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
في المخيم بعد ان حاصرت القوات
الاسرائيليه منزلا واندلعت اشتباكات عنيفه
على اثرها تتزامن احداث جنين هذه مع
اقتحام الجيش الاسرائيلي المدينه
واعتقال عدد من الفلسطينيين ايضا
شباب هيا هيا هيا
هياها هياها يا شباب
كما افاد مراس العربيه باسقاط طائره مسيره
للقوات الاسرائيليه في مخيم جنين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الضربات الاسرائيليه على سوريا لا تغيب
طويلا ووجهتها في معظم الاحيان المطارات
حيث ادت الضربه الاسرائيليه التي استهدفت
مطار حلب شمالي سوريا الى اضرار في
المدرجات اخرجته عن الخدمه في حين اعلنت
المؤسسه العامه للطيران في وزاره النقل
تحويله هبوطي طائرات المساعدات الاراديه
والرحلات الجويه الاخرى في مطاري دمشق
واللاذقيه مشيره الى مباشره عمليات الكشف
عن الاضرار وازالتها تمهيدا لاصلاحها
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه استخبارات كوريا
الجنوبيه تقول ان زعيم بيونغ يونغ لديه
ابن بكر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قالت السنه الامريكيه
مارك وارنار انه يعتزم تقديم المشروع
قانون هذا الاسبوع يهدف الى السماح
للحكومه بحظر او منع منتجات تكنولوجيه
اجنبيه وخاصه منصه تيك توك المملوكه لشركه
صينيه
اداره بايدن تريد الصلاحيه للتعامل مع
مخاطر التيك توك للتاكد من ان البيانات
الحساسه ليست مكشوفه للصين من اجل الحصول
على هذا النوع من الرقابه يدفع البيت
الابيض الكونجرس لمنحه سلطه قانونيه على
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي يتم تطوير هذا
التشريع من قبل السيناتور الديمقراطي مارك
وارنار واذا تمريره يمكن ان يكون للحكومه
الامريكيه سلطه حظر تيك توك المملوكه
للصينيين بشكل كامل من الولايات المتحده
لكن حسب نيويورك تايمز ليس هذا هو الهدف
فكره التشريع هي السماح لتيك توك بالعمل
في الولايات المتحده ولكن تحت اعين
الحكومه الساهره يبدو ان منصه تيك توك على
وشك ان تصبح احدث اضافه في حرب
التكنولوجيا بين واشنطن وبكين حرب تنطوي
على العديد من الفصول الاخرى ابرزها
بعنوان الرقائق الدقيقه
في السنوات الاخيره انفقت الولايات
المتحده 52 مليار دولار على تصنيع اشباه
الموصلات المحليه لتقليل اعتماد امريكا
على رقائق الكمبيوتر المصنوعه في اسيا
بينما منعت الصين منذ فتره طويله العديد
من الخدمات الامريكيه عبر الانترنت ابرزها
جوجل ومتى ويوتيوب
[موسيقى]
والى عالم التكنولوجيا والفضاء ضربه جديده
تلقتها طوكيو في جهودها الراميه الى خفض
تكلفه الوصول الى الفضاء ومنافسه شركه فيس
اكس المملوكه لرجل الامريكي ايلون ماسك
حيث فشلت اليابان في اطلاق صاروخ جديده في
رحلته الاولى الى الفضاء بعد عدم اشتعال
محرك دفع المرحله الثانيه للصاروخ كما كان
مخطط له واظهر فيديو لحظه انطلاق الصاروخ
الذي يبلغ ارتفاعه 57 مترا دون اي عوائق
ولكن بمجرد وصوله الى الفضاء فاشله في
الاستمرار
[موسيقى]
خطه جديده للحكومه البريطانيه لوقف تدفق
المهاجرين غير القانونيين عبر القناه
الانجليزيه الخطه التي اعلنتها الثلاثاء
وزيره الداخليه صويلا برايفرمان تعطي
صلاحيات اوسع للداخليه قد تصل حد الابعاد
والمنع من الدخول الى البلاد مستقبلا
محاوله قانونيه جديده تتوافق كما تقول
حكومه البريطانيه مع التزامات القانون
الدولي هدفها وقف تدفق المهاجرين غير
القانونيين تشريع جديد لحكومه يعطي
صلاحيات اوسع لوزيره الداخليه البريطانيه
بشكل غير قانوني مرورا بعدم النظر في طلب
لجؤه وصولا الى ابعاده بسرعه ومنعه من
دخول البلاد في المستقبل
لن يتوقف المهاجرون عن القدوم الى بلدنا
حتى يعرف العالم ان كل من يدخل بريطانيا
بشكل غير قانوني سيتم احتجازه واعادته
بسرعه الى بلده اذا كان امنا او الى دوله
ثالثه امنه مثل رواندا وهذا بالضبط ما
سيفعله هذا القانون لوقف القوارب
القانون الجديد يسمح باحتجاز الوافدين غير
القانونيين ل 28 يوما دون امكانيه الافراج
عنهم بكفاله او مراجعه قضائيه حتى يرحل
الى خارج البلاد لكن الخطه اثارت حفيظه
المنظمات الحقوقيه المعنيه ووصفتها بغير
الانسانيه كما لم تحظى بتاييد احزاب
المعارضه التي اعتبرتها غير فعاله ما لم
تتفاوض الحكومه مع دول مثل فرنسا
ما المختلف هذه المره ليس للحكومه اي
اتفاقيات سريه لاعاده المهاجرين وحتى اذا
استمرت في عدد المرحلين لا يتعدى بضع مئات
من الاشخاص اذا ما الذي سيحدث لتسعه
وتسعين في المئه من المهاجرين الاخرين
بموجب هذا القانون
وبحسب وزاره الداخليه فان 85 الف مهاجر
وصلوا بريطانيا بطرق غير قانونيه منذ 2018
منهم 45,000 طالب لجوء ويكلفون دافع
الضرائب سته ملايين جنيه يوميا لاوائهم في
الفنادق رغم الانتقادات الواسعه لخطه وقف
قوارب المهاجرين غير النظاميين الى
الاراضي البريطانيه تبدو حكومه ريسسوناك
مصره على
تنفيذ احدى اولوياته الخمسه التي تعهد بها
هكذا تترك للنخب الحكم عليها على مدى
قدرتها على الوفاء بها قبل الانتخابات
العامه المقبله مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن
[موسيقى]
في كوريا الجنوبيه تفاصيل جديده تتكشف عن
عدد اطفال زعيم البلاد كيم جونغ اون التي
ظلت لي سنين طويله مجهوله حيث كشفت
الاستخبارات في سول عن معلومات مهمه تتعلق
بهم نتابعها بهذا التقرير
استخبارات سيول تكشف حقائق جديده عن حياه
زعيم كوريا الشماليه الذي لطالما اخفاها
عن وسائل الاعلام واعين شعبه ايضا جدل
كبير سببه هذه المره اطفال كيم جونغ اون
صاحب الاستعراضات النوويه الاستخبارات
كشفت عن عدد ابناء الزعيم ثلاثه اولاد
البكر ذكر والثانيه انثى والثالث لم يحدد
اوسطهم ابنته كيم جو اي التي ظهرت معه في
اكثر من مناسبه اخرها عندما تم اختبار
الصواريخ الباليستيه العابره للقارات وهي
خطوه تنذر باحتمال انتقال الزعامه لجيل
رابع من عائلتكيم وفقا للمشرعين الذين
اطلعتهم المخابرات الوطنيه الكوريه
الجنوبيه على المعلومات فان البنت الثانيه
التي باتت رفيقه والدها لم يتم رصد اسمها
في ايه مؤسسه تعليميه وانها تت تعليمها من
المنزل وصدر مرسوم بمنع المواطنين من
تسميه اسمها ومن له اسمها قبل ولادتها
عليه ان يغيره لكن اطفالكم الاول والثالثه
لم يروا علنا ابدا وليس هناك اي دليل مفصل
عنهم سوى ان اول طفل له ولد في عام 2010
وسط انباء انه يعاني من مشاكل جسديه
وعقليه لم يتم تاكيدها بسبب الرقابه
الصارمه والمعلومه الوحيده ان الطفل
الثالث ولد في فبراير 2017 وعمره الان ست
سنوات تقريبا وفق مراقبين كوريا الشماليه
تعتبر دوله مغلقه بشكل كبير عن البلدان
الاخرى ومن الصعب التحقق من المعلومات
المتعلقه بمجتمعها وحكومتها وخاصه عن
الرئيس وعائلته
اخبار الساعه انتهت تفكير بابرزها
زعيمر يعترف بشراسه في القتال ويرد على
شيغو نحن من قتلنا في ضخمه وليس جيشك
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه واكد انفتاح
المملكه على الحوار مع ايران وان الاتفاق
النووي يجب ان يعالج مخاوف دول الجوار
عشرون محاميا ايرانيا يطالبون منظمات
دوليه بتشكيل لجنه مستقله للتحقيق في قضيه
تصميم الطالبات في ايران تيك توك الصيني
ضمن مشروع قرار امريكي يستهدف شركات
التكنولوجيا الصينيه
شكرا لكم على كرمي متابعه اخبار الساعه
لهذه الليله الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]